okay we have a voicemail number two one
nine two David P I'm worried about Troy
York
Troy York is a longtime caller who often
calls in with different characters he
has a Hispanic character whose name is
like Louis something or Ramon Ramos or
something like that he has a a black
college character called I think it's
like Jamal Jenkins or something like
that he has all these characters he
plays he's a right-wing extremist he
left a voicemail right this morning or
maybe late last night and I'm actually
really worried about Troy hora take a
listen to this he doesn't sound good I'd
like to know why you have not mentioned
the fact that we are getting nine
hundred million dollars of the drug for
chatter Ford pitcher of El Chapo Joaquin
Guzman the drug runner money from Mexico
to use to build the wall you just want
to push the narrative that Mexico is not
paying for the wall but in fact the wall
is going up and we are using the drug
proceeds run drug running money of nine
hundred million dollars who in effect
use and pay for part of the wall that
will be put up whether you are chanting
Venezuelan Israeli trans nationalist son
of a pig like Internet hmm yeah
something sounds very wrong with Troy
and I am worried about him and of course
even if 900 million dollars seized from
El Chapo were applied to the wall that
gets you like 25 miles based on what the
wall costs so I I don't know that I even
need to respond to the content but Troy
get get some help I'm worried about you
buddy we've got a great bonus show today
we will talk about migrant families at
the border we will talk about another
Baker LGBT story that has been going on
and we will also talk about Senator Rand
Paul's recent statements about
vaccinations all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show the bonus
show is for members and patrons only
sign up on our website make a pledge at
patreon and I will speak to you then